game review game review hello my name is
Caleb Dendy and today we're gonna be
doing a game from the Tata Steel Masters
Tournament where ali reza fruga who's
off to a hot start ran into the one the
only Magnus Carlsen so today we'll see
how that game went and see some ideas
and playing with a little space versus
playing with a lot of space so let's
just jump into it the game started with
E 4 E 5 a fairly common opening as those
of you who play chess may or may already
know the Royal apes' Knight f6
signifying the berlin white plays D 3
and d 6a avoiding of course the endgame
line after C 3 we see a 6 for Magnus
Bishop a4 and Bishop e7 not the most
common line but definitely it has been
tested before castles castles the cert
comes to e1 the cert comes to e8 no
Knight bTW to spaceship comes back to f8
and we see h3 preventing any pins and
now b5 from black Bishop c2 Bishop e7
and d4 so I won't go into all the
opening nuances of the Royal apes'
because I don't understand them however
g6 from black here aims to give this
bishop some options along this diagonal
and the theme of the game is going to be
that white has this nice little Center
and black is going to be trying to
challenge it in various ways and we'll
see actually after a three and night b8
black is rerouting this night perhaps to
d7 as well as freeing up the option to
bring this pawn out to c5 or even to c6
depending on how the game continues and
here white made of a very very strange
choice I think Frazier was a little bit
hasty in his decisions here there are
some ideas for white in this position
like a for trying to break down this b5
pawn as well as b4 with the idea of a
later a4 you can also play things
perhaps like Knight f1 maybe bring this
Knight out to to this side of the board
although
you have to be careful I don't think you
can play Knight f1 here due to the EEP
EEP on being hanging even a move like b3
can't can be played but the move that
ali reza play it is very committal you
played d5 here which is taking a lot of
space but the downside to having space
is always that you're leaving weaknesses
behind in this case the c5 square is a
very very relevant weakness that is
being left behind you might think well
we have this move b4 if we ever need it
to protect the c5 square but magnus
ensured that b4 was never really going
to be a problem for him and he did so by
playing the annoying moves c6 by playing
this move you're challenging the white
center immediately and you're kind of
forcing white to play a move like c4 to
defend this center d takes c6 is
playable but after Bishop takes they're
gonna run into an eventual d5 and the
black pieces are really going to be
freed by this so instead I'll agree as
it does choose c4 but now after a few
more moves we see 9b d7 like I said
aiming for the c5 square we see a4 from
white hoping to break down this b5 pawn
but now simply Queen c7 eyeing some
pieces on this open fight or soon to be
open file here and now after b3 you can
really see why does committing to
defending these pawns on the light
squares that's leaving behind the c5
square which is very very relevant so
now I wanted to talk about how good at
chess Magnus Carlsen is it's a topic
that has not been explored very much I
know but he really understands this
position well I think judging from this
game when you are down in space the the
downside to having a lack of space is
usually that your pieces don't have
squares you just don't have enough
squares to put your pieces on but here
despite White's massive centre Magnus
actually finds great squares for all of
his pieces and then white space
advantage turns out to be rather useless
he does so by starting with Rick ec8
like I said eyeing the pieces on this
file and now after rook a - he
takes on c4 and takes on c4 and then
I'll let you at home try and find
Magnus's next move because it's actually
a very very nice move it's the best move
in the position and it guarantees that
this bishop will have a home in the
future an active space to be on all
right good luck hopefully you found it
it is a five smooth guarantees this
bishop will have an open diagonal where
it can I some weaknesses in the white
position and if we just take a quick
look at how the pieces are organized the
black rooks
the black rook and Queen are placed on a
file which could open at any moment at
blacks choosing this rook will have an
open B file to go to this bishop will
have an a6 squared to go to this Knight
is well placed on f6 challenging the
white EEP on this night can come to c5
challenging two white weaknesses this
bishop can come out to h6 another open
diagonal all of black's pieces have very
very active squares to go to and white
is actually kind of trapped by his own
space he's trapped behind his own pawns
and these Knights look rather awkward
these rooks are a little disc ordinated
uncoordinated even and the fact is the
space that ali reza has is useless if
his pieces can't find squares and magnus
found active squares for all of his
pieces rather effortlessly here and
because of that black is simply better
in this position white does continue
with Knight f1 trying to improve his own
pieces special comes out to a6 like we
expected 93 defends this weakness but
now Knight c5 92 and white is taking a
purely defensive stance for the moment
white or black chooses this moment to
open up this C file and now like we said
this rook has a nice home on the B file
especially comes out to a3 this Queen
actually comes back to d8 now allowing
for this rook to recapture on c5 and
eyeing some squares in the Kings side as
well this Queen comes out to f3
Magnus of course has already defended
this knight now we see h5 from Magnus
taking some Kings side space for himself
rook a to a-1 for Perugia
now Bishop h6 and this is really the
moment where you see Magnus had a plan
for all of his pieces this bishop comes
out this way this queen eyes some
squares on the Kings side these Knights
attacking these weaknesses in this
Bishop as well also eyeing some
important squares with the rooks on the
open files this is exactly what you want
to do when you have less space if you
have squares for your pieces you're
happy rook a b1 is played after a trade
we see it King g7 for Magnus shoring up
these pieces night e to F one is
ferocious choice now H for further
cramps
these white knights Knight e3 and this
Bishop comes to f4 and the threats are
starting to mount on White's Kings side
and fruga simply plays Knight e to f1
again perhaps he's he's lacking some
some options here to improve his pieces
so he resorts to repeating this Queen
comes out to c7 looking at some
dangerous squares g3 is ferruginous
attempt at freeing his pieces but after
H takes and F takes this bishop just
straps back to age 4 and after age 4
Queen d7 g3 has actually just weakened
White's position a little bit too much
King G - but this Queen was actually
forking these two squares so now Knight
takes a 4 and the end is near we see
this trade you see we do see this Bishop
capture on d6 but now Queen d4 is a nice
move hitting this night on d2 and after
Queen f2 Queen takes f2 King takes f2
Magnus's next move actually forces
resignation that move is Bishop takes f1
White has three choices to recapture
this bishop but in fact all of them end
up losing a piece King takes or rook
takes both fail - Bishop takes d2 and if
you play Knight takes D - there's this
very annoying check 90 for picking up
the bishop so Magnus simply ends up
winning a piece at the end of the day so
I think this game was a very instructive
way to show how to play with less space
you just find squares for your pieces
and then you don't really have to worry
about your lack of space
at all magnus carlsen once again showing
my he's magnus carlsen why he's the
number one player in the world really
dominating Forja in this game well thank
you very much for joining me for this
episode of game review as always my name
is Caleb Denby and I will see you next
time